El método de diagonalización cuántica basada en muestras, o SQD por sus siglas, es un algoritmo híbrido cuántico-clásico, como Krylov
quantum diagonalization KQD, como VQE y muchos otros. Al usar estos híbridos
algoritmos, puede ser útil pensar en dónde cada algoritmo aprovecha la computación cuántica y la clásica. Recuerda que VQE crea estados en un quantum
circuit usando parámetros optimizados clásicamente. En ese caso, el estado en sí está en una computadora cuántica. Sin embargo,
obtener el estado objetivo es un proceso que combina computación clásica y cuántica.
El valor esperado del operador se calcula usando mediciones cuánticas.
Pero también es necesaria cierta combinación clásica de términos.
En contraste, SQD usa una computadora cuántica para generar un subespacio útil sobre el que se puede proyectar el Hamiltoniano u otro operador.
El Hamiltoniano se diagonaliza entonces de forma completamente clásica para encontrar el estado objetivo. Supón que tenemos un
problema de interés científico o industrial que puede formularse como un problema de solver de valores propios sobre una matriz de n filas y
n columnas. Supón además que n es lo suficientemente grande como para que la diagonalización clásica exacta no sea una opción. Claramente,
sería ventajoso reducir las dimensiones de nuestra matriz conservando todas las características relevantes del estado base. Ese es, en efecto,
el objetivo de muchos enfoques aproximados de solver de valores propios, incluidos los métodos clásicos de Krylov. Supongamos que sabemos lo suficiente sobre nuestro problema para hacer una
suposición razonablemente buena sobre la forma del estado base, pero no lo suficiente para resolver el problema directamente. En ese
caso, podríamos hacer muchas mediciones de nuestra aproximación razonable del estado base objetivo. Los resultados de estas
mediciones nos dan un subespacio de estados de la base computacional que contienen todos los componentes relevantes de nuestro
estado base. Proyectar sobre ese subespacio daría una matriz más pequeña que aún contiene los grados de libertad relevantes.
El flujo de trabajo para esto es el siguiente. Comienzas eligiendo un buen
anzot. Más precisamente, elige un anzot cuyo soporte coincida con el del estado objetivo. Discutiremos exactamente qué
significa eso. A continuación, mide el estado en la base computacional, como se hace con el primitivo sampler.
Luego, usa los resultados del muestreo para definir un subespacio que contenga el estado base.
Después, proyecta tu matriz sobre ese subespacio. Por último, diagonaliza clásicamente la matriz proyectada más pequeña.
Analicemos cada uno de estos pasos, prestando especial atención a la definición del subespacio.
En toda la computación cuántica, elegir un buen ansatz siempre es fundamental. En el caso de SQD, tu elección de ANSOT
determinará qué estados de la base computacional pueden medirse en el muestreo.
El verdadero estado base puede expresarse como una superposición de algún subconjunto de estados de la base computacional. Ese subconjunto
se llama el soporte del estado base. Para obtener una buena estimación de tu estado base y su energía, tus anzots
deben tener una proyección no nula sobre los estados de la base computacional en el soporte del estado base.
Este diagrama representa el espacio abarcado por todos los estados posibles en el número de qubits que se están usando. Queremos un
anzot cuyo soporte contenga el soporte del verdadero estado base.
Considera un sistema de ejemplo muy pequeño con un estado base de s base es 8 *
el estado 1 0 0 más 6 * el estado 0 0 1.
Esto tiene un soporte formado por esos dos vectores 1 0 0 y 0 0 1. Digamos que el Anzots tiene la forma SNZOT 1 que es A veces
el estado 1 0 0 más B * el estado 0 1 0 más C * el estado 0 0 1. De modo que su
soporte es el conjunto de tres vectores 1 0 0, 0 1 0 y 0 0 1, un superconjunto del
soporte del estado base. Este es un buen anzot.
Ahora imagina que en su lugar hubiéramos elegido un anzot de la forma szots 2 que es a * el
estado 1 1 0 más b * el estado 0 1 1.
Esto tiene un soporte formado por esos dos vectores 1 1 0 y 0 1 1, que no tiene ningún solapamiento con el soporte del estado
base. Este es un mal anzot.
Nota que no necesariamente requerimos que el unzots sea una buena aproximación del estado base. El unzots podría
tener un soporte mucho mayor o los coeficientes podrían ser muy diferentes entre el anzots y el verdadero estado base y aun así funcionar bien.
En esta etapa, hemos usado un ansatz bien motivado para que la computadora cuántica adopte un estado similar a nuestro objetivo.
Aquí se muestra el unitary coupled gastro o UCJ unzots, que es muy útil en química cuántica.
Ahora queremos medir el estado del sistema obteniendo cadenas de bits que describan el estado colapsado de cada
qubit. Recuerda que la estimación del Hamiltoniano, como en VQE, requiere muchas mediciones cuánticas. Esto se debe en parte a
reducir la incertidumbre y en parte al número de grupos de Paulis conmutadores que componen el Hamiltoniano.
En los métodos de muestreo, aún necesitas muchas mediciones, pero las razones son distintas. Ahora necesitamos muchas mediciones para muestrear eficazmente los
muchos estados de la base computacional involucrados en estados cuánticos altamente entrelazados. En SQD, las cadenas de bits muestreadas corresponden
a configuraciones del sistema simulado. Si el sistema que se estudia está sujeto a restricciones absolutas, como
leyes de conservación en física o química, entonces la mayoría de los estados medidos serán válidos. Pero algunas cadenas de bits muestreadas
corresponden a configuraciones inválidas o no físicas debido al ruido y los errores. Un proceso llamado
recuperación de configuración busca refinar estas muestras ruidosas en un conjunto de configuraciones más precisas.
Este proceso implica generar nuevas configuraciones volteando probabilísticamente bits individuales basándose en
ocupaciones orbitales promediadas y números de partículas conocidos.
Las configuraciones refinadas se usan luego para abarcar subespacios para la proyección y diagonalización del Hamiltoniano,
mejorando iterativamente la fidelidad de la representación del estado cuántico.
Veamos un ejemplo trivialmente pequeño de recuperación de configuración para entender su significado. Supón que medimos un
sistema cuántico con cuatro qubits que representan cuatro orbitales moleculares y obtenemos las siguientes cadenas de bits del
procesador cuántico. Cada cadena de bits representa la ocupación de un orbital. Uno para
ocupado, cero para desocupado. Qiskit usa una notación en la que el qubit menos significativo está en el extremo derecho.
Por ejemplo, 1 0 1 0 indica que los orbitales 1 y 3 están ocupados. Estas
mediciones se han elegido únicamente por razones pedagógicas. Las ocupaciones resultantes pueden no corresponder a un sistema físico. En contextos físicos, es
frecuente que el sistema tenga un número total conocido de partículas. También puede haber otras leyes de conservación que
puedes aprovechar para determinar la fisicalidad de un estado medido. Para ser concretos, supongamos que nuestro sistema
tiene un número total de partículas conocido de n= 2. Esto nos dice el número total de unos que deben aparecer en la etiqueta de nuestro estado,
lo que se llama una restricción de peso de Hamming.
Sin embargo, algunas configuraciones medidas violan esta restricción. El estado 1 0 1 0 es físicamente válido. Pero el estado 1 1
1 0 tiene demasiadas partículas y el estado de todos ceros tiene muy pocas partículas. Cero
de hecho. Estas violaciones pueden deberse al ruido en el sistema o a errores en la medición. Necesitamos una forma de volver
a configuraciones que tengan sentido físico, al menos de forma aproximada.
Esto se llama recuperación de configuración.
Para corregir nuestras muestras ruidosas, invertimos bits de forma probabilística en configuraciones inválidas basándonos en la
ocupación orbital promedio calculada sobre las configuraciones válidas.
Las ocupaciones orbitales son los valores de expectación del operador de número actuando sobre cada orbital. Esto se estima y
se refina de forma autoconsistente usando los estados producidos por SQD. Veamos el orbital 2, por ejemplo. En dos de las
cuatro configuraciones válidas, el orbital 2 estaba ocupado. Esto nos da una ocupación esperada de 0.5.
Hacemos lo mismo para los otros tres orbitales. Ahora volvemos a una configuración inválida 1 1 0. Podemos invertir uno de
los bits de 1 a cero para generar una configuración válida. ¿Pero cuál debemos invertir? Una forma de decidirlo es
a través de la desviación de la ocupación de cada orbital respecto a los promedios que acabamos de calcular.
Aquí vemos que la mayor diferencia está en la ocupación del orbital uno. Así que podríamos esperar que el bit uno deba
invertirse de uno a cero. Por supuesto, el orbital 2 no se queda atrás. Y siempre es posible, aunque poco probable, que
este estado medido sea el resultado de múltiples errores sobre el mismo estado.
Elegir solo la mayor desviación respecto a la media para todos los estados inválidos no es óptimo. En cambio, los bits se invierten
probabilísticamente, siendo la probabilidad una función de las diferencias mostradas aquí. Supongamos que en este
caso sí cambiamos el bit que más difiere de la ocupación promedio. Así que 1 1 0 se convierte en 1 1 0 0. Haríamos lo
mismo para la otra elección inválida. Digamos que en este caso terminamos invirtiendo los bits uno y tres.
Tras este proceso de corrección, tenemos un nuevo conjunto de configuraciones que podría verse así.
Usando este conjunto refinado, podemos actualizar la ocupación orbital promedio para mejorar la fidelidad. En nuestro caso, las nuevas
ocupaciones son estas.
Este proceso de recuperación iterativa garantiza que las mediciones ruidosas se filtren en configuraciones físicamente significativas,
mejorando la precisión de las aproximaciones de estados propios en SQD. El complemento de Qiskit para SQD tiene algunas herramientas que
serán fundamentales en este proceso. Si hemos hecho un buen trabajo muestreando los estados en el soporte del verdadero estado fundamental
del sistema, entonces deberíamos poder observar solo las partes del Hamiltoniano que actúan sobre este subespacio
y aun así obtener un buen estado fundamental y energía. En nuestro ejemplo trivialmente pequeño de 4 qubit, inicialmente hay 2 o 16
posibles estados del sistema. Usando una combinación de muestreo y recuperación de configuración, reducimos esto
a tres estados en nuestro subespacio de interés: tres estados que esperamos que constituyan el soporte del verdadero estado fundamental.
Ahora proyectamos nuestro Hamiltoniano completo sobre ese subespacio. Es decir, formamos una matriz M a partir de una columna de vectores de nuestro
subespacio muestreado recuperado y una análoga M dagger a partir de las filas, y multiplicamos M dagger HM
pictóricamente. Esto significa tomar los elementos matriciales en las filas y columnas correspondientes a los estados de nuestro
subespacio muestreado recuperado. Las filas y columnas resaltadas son las que corresponden a nuestro subespacio. Y las
cajas resaltadas más oscuras donde se superponen son los elementos que conservamos para nuestra nueva matriz proyectada.
Ahora que hemos seleccionado el subespacio de interés, podemos diagonalizar esta matriz en un ordenador clásico
usando un solucionador estándar. Si el verdadero estado fundamental está compuesto enteramente de estados en nuestro subespacio, esta
diagonalización debería producir el estado fundamental correcto y la energía del estado fundamental. Si solo tenemos la mayor parte del soporte del estado fundamental,
podríamos acercarnos. Una vez obtenido el estado fundamental para este Hamiltoniano proyectado, tenemos un
estado muy útil a partir del cual calcular la ocupación orbital promedio de cada orbital.
Anteriormente, nuestras ocupaciones se calculaban a partir de estados que muestreamos usando un ansatz que esperábamos que nos ayudara
a aproximarnos a nuestro estado fundamental. Pero no había garantía de que la ocupación orbital promedio de ese muestreo correspondiera a la ocupación
en el estado de menor energía. Retrocedamos. Teníamos un muestreo de estados computacionales. Usamos la recuperación de configuración
para corregir los que eran físicamente inválidos. Luego calculamos la ocupación orbital promedio usando todos ellos. El
estado fundamental podría incluir solo algunos de ellos. El estado fundamental de este Hamiltoniano proyectado puede no ser el verdadero estado fundamental
de nuestro sistema original, pero es el estado de menor energía que se puede crear usando cualquier superposición de los
estados recuperados en nuestro subespacio. La ocupación orbital de este estado producirá una energía menor o igual a
la energía de la ocupación obtenida del espacio recuperado. Por lo tanto, esta ocupación es una mejor estimación de nuestra
ocupación del estado fundamental. Podemos repetir el proceso de recuperación de configuración usando esta nueva ocupación y podemos iterar
esto hasta que se cumplan nuestros criterios de convergencia. La diagonalización cuántica basada en muestreo es rápida en comparación con
otros algoritmos de corto plazo como VQE. Es más escalable y es robusta al ruido y los errores en el muestreo. Aún
requiere que preparemos un buen ansatz con una gran proyección bajo el soporte del verdadero estado fundamental de nuestro sistema. Si no se sabe nada en absoluto
sobre nuestro verdadero estado fundamental, SQD puede necesitar usarse junto con otros métodos para aprender primero sobre el
estado fundamental y aproximarse a él iterativamente.
SQD juega un papel fundamental en el emergente conjunto de algoritmos híbridos clásico-cuánticos y es uno de los
mayores impulsores hacia la computación cuántica útil.